erica congratulations on being the first
canadian to ever win survivor how are
you feeling
oh my gosh it i feel amazing i can
finally tell the world say it over and
over again morgan i'm the first canadian
to ever win survivor
we're so proud of you now this is pretty
wild because this is the first time
since season one am i right that jeff
announced you as the winner while still
on location so you've had to keep this a
secret for months
oh yeah i was shocked when jeff read the
votes right away
was not expecting that at all but for
the last few months i haven't told
anyone i haven't told my family i
haven't told any of my friends so i've
just been walking around with this big
secret um for so long and it's so fun to
be able to share this dream come true
news with everyone
what was it like for you watching your
family and their reaction to you winning
oh my goodness you know there are a few
moments over the last few months where i
thought okay maybe i tell my family what
happened but it was so worth it to keep
the secret because all of my siblings my
parents just broke down into tears even
i started crying seeing their reaction
it was just
uh one of the happiest moments of my
life
honestly i don't know if i could have
kept that a secret so seriously kudos to
you
that's amazing
um so look you are a million dollars
richer and because you're canadian i
mean this is a tax-free
winning which is so cool what are you
gonna do with the money
i mean first priority is my parents i
have to make sure they have whatever
they need to live a comfortable life a
second priority maybe irresponsible but
there's a lot of expensive shoes i want
and then after that i'll do all the
smart stuff you do with money
like when you talk shoes are you like
heels boots like what kind of shoes i
need to know
select all i mean hey i got a lot of
money let's go for it oh my gosh i feel
like this is the best and maybe no i'm
not gonna say the worst you have so much
money you can buy whatever you want when
it comes to shoes that's so cool um you
know what's so exciting for you i mean i
i interviewed you before this season
even started um and i i read or the the
last time you spoke to us you said that
you read about the audition for survivor
uh by reading an e.t canada article so
can we take a little bit of credit for
your success
oh my goodness it's actually pretty
crazy because when et canada first
announced that canadians could be on
survivor i sat in this room and made my
audition tape and then i talked to you a
few months ago before survivor aired
same room and now here i am talking to
you about how i won so eg canada has
been a part of the journey from the
beginning listen we're going to take
credit okay for all your hard work we're
going to take a little bit of credit i'm
happy to share with you guys that's so
cool um you know you've really made a
name for yourself in this game of course
as a canadian i'm so proud that you're
the first canadian to win a survivor but
you're also the first person of filipino
descent and you're also the first woman
to win after several seasons you know
when you think about everything that
you've accomplished what do you think
about
um you naming all of these stats just
almost brings tears to my eyes because
i just went to i went into survivor
deciding i want to relieve myself of the
pressure of having to prove anything to
anybody i'm just going to go as myself
and play with any strengths and
weaknesses that i have and then knowing
that that game where i truly was
authentic to who i am was what led me to
the win and led me to represent all of
these communities it's overwhelming it's
an honor i'm so grateful to all of the
support i've got from all different fans
you i'm gonna start crying now i've just
gotten so much support and
it's truly an honor to help people feel
seen on tv oh my gosh i can't even
imagine you know like put aside all the
games and all the endurance but then to
to feel the way you're feeling now is
just
you know that is that is so special
because not everybody gets to to have an
experience like this and you took that
opportunity and you
went for it
gosh thank you yeah thank you so much i
mean
yeah it's it's hard to describe truly i
think that
you you don't understand the impact of
you being on tv until you're actually on
tv and you realize that
you know me being myself making jokes
about how i'll literally kill ricard
like means a lot to people
yeah it's true um so i love this in 2010
you tweeted by the way still watch
survivor
so if you could go back in time and tell
yourself that in just 10 years you would
be the winner the first canadian winner
of survivor what would you tell yourself
oh i would tell i would probably i think
i have to quote tweet that tweet and
then tell myself what i would say
i think that at that time when i tweeted
that it it felt like it was impossible
for me to play survivor because it was
it i there wasn't even a game that i was
eligible to play so i think that if i
went back in time and talked to myself
that old version of me would have just
collapsed yeah i collapsed i love that
yeah just i'm done
um you know aside from winning which is
so exciting do you feel like a different
person after going through these
challenges
100 i think that
coming back from the game i realized i
did something super hard
and what was amazing is
who i was was enough
all of the strengths i had all the
weaknesses i had that was enough as long
as i trusted myself and i really
um like accepted the person that i was
and afterwards i decided like
i can do anything truly i can do
anything
and i hope that through watching my
journey people feel the same way
absolutely and just to wrap things up
with the holidays right around the
corner i mean is there pressure now that
you got to get everyone like really good
gifts oh my gosh so i've been so wrapped
up with the show that i haven't done any
christmas shopping and now i'm thinking
uh oh
um no no i'm happy to give my family a
good christmas so they're the
beneficiaries of this win too i love
that hey congratulations from getting to
talk to you before we saw the show to
now what a moment for you just take it
all in
thank you so much morgan and honestly
thank you et canada for being part of
the journey